the way we get married has changed very
little for centuries but what we expect
from marriages has changed beyond
recognition we know so much now about
why marriages go wrong but so little of
that knowledge ever makes it into the
wedding ceremony itself that's why we've
decided to redesign the marriage
ceremony creating a modern event that's
more realistic and more psychological
and therefore better able to help a
couple with the joys and sorrows of life
together people still long for ritual
and formality a wedding remains a big
deal and it's good to reflect that in
the dignity of the clothes and the
setting let's listen in on what happens
in our designed marriage ceremony we are
gathered today for a solemn event
profoundly hopeful but infinitely
difficult we're here to celebrate the
wedding of Emily and Simon a good
marriage is not one from which troubles
are magically absent it is one in which
troubles are faced with insight and
generosity there are a series of rituals
in the wedding ceremony things kick off
with what's called the ritual of
humility humility is probably the most
important emotion for the success of a
relationship
humility starts with an ample accurate
and sorrowful recognition of all one's
failings it is filled with apology and
modesty it doesn't pretend that flaws
are charming quirks or excusable
oddities it contains an open admission
that we wish we were different and
better Simon do you admit that you're a
failed broken human being not in every
way but in some ways so serious that you
will at points be a grave burden to
Emily yes I admit I am failed and broken
before coming here today freely and
openly and after careful reflection you
have listed your failings as you
recognize them you've listed them in
this book this is your book
of imperfections would you now before me
your partner and your guests read some
of what you have stated in your own
words I acknowledge that are not good at
communicating my feelings maturely I
won't say what's bothering me but
instead sulk and expect you to read my
mind and get furious at you and you
can't I can be quite self-involved I
tend to assume that if you're upset it's
something about me I get jealous even
over small incidents and become petty
and hateful instead of showing that I'm
afraid of losing you both partners admit
to their multiple faults
self-righteousness is after all the
great enemy of love neither of us is
fully sane or healthy we are committed
to treating each other as broken people
with enormous kindness and imagination
when we manage it
there is nothing odd about this couple
beyond the ordinary oddness that is
everyone's lot they've merely put into
words the errors and failings of which
we are all continuously guilty
[Music]
next comes what we call the ritual of
charity charity is at the heart of love
charity means finding the least alarming
least panicked view of why the other is
acting as they are it sees the fear
behind the aggression it sees the
loneliness at the root of a sulk it
recognizes how shame can make a person
defiant and how a hidden worry can
unleash excessive harshness will you now
exchange the ritual gifts of charity a
couple are exchanging photographs of one
another from childhood we naturally act
towards a child with a spirit of love we
often find it hard to adopt towards
adults this exchange of childhood images
symbolizes a commitment to treat one
another with the kindness one wouldn't
hesitate to show a child but so often
refuse grown-ups or it will place this
child version of you that was the center
of my love I will try to see your faults
as a consequence of troubles in your
past I will look after the broken child
within you
[Music]
lastly comes the exchange of rings and a
spousal valve knowing all this fearing
all this hoping all this will you in
front of us all bow to Wed each other
will you agree to share your lives with
all the restraint and sorrow that will
be involved as well as the joy and the
kindness and the friendship we did I now
declare you married
[Applause]
no marriage is ever without serious
challenges but starting a marriage with
a wedding ceremony that's alive to these
challenges and gives us some gentle
guidance on how to avoid them helps us
to get off on the right footing
[Music]
if you'd like to buy the book how to get
married which has our full marriage
service in it along with advice on
preparing for and managing marriage
please click the link on screen now and
if you'd like our help in actually
putting on your own marriage service
please contact us by the link in the
description